hey guys it is the 18th of May today my
name is just McDonald and you're
watching gamespot news first up today
Xbox boss Phil Spencer said more JRPGs
could be on their way to Xbox one when
asked why I fan on Twitter if any JRPGs
were in the works for the console
Spencer replied it's a good and fair
question keep asking until we show you
something you like I can't share any
specific plans now sorry in november of
last year Phil Spencer promised Jay RPG
fans that they would see more of the
genre on Xbox one Microsoft's consoles
have been home to a few exclusive JRPGs
in the past like Blue Dragon and almost
Odyssey both of which came from the
creator of Final Fantasy para no booze
Sakaguchi currently the call for more
JRPGs on Xbox one has attracted over
3500 votes on the Xbox feedback side do
infants have something to be excited
about today as Bethesda have just
released a 10 second teaser video for
the upcoming FPS the blink and you'll
miss it trailer has about 30 seconds of
gameplay featuring a gun being loaded
and the beastie with shoulder mounted
guns taking up the other seven seconds
of the video is the games logo and the
confirmation that dooms worldwide
gameplay reveal will take place at the
Thursday c3 showcase on jun 14 at seven
p.m. PT if you're desperate for more
seconds of doom teasing and don't forget
they released a 45 second teaser at last
year's e3 finally soda projects have
released of the witcher 3 stay one patch
notes the pouch contains fixes for
stability and overall performance
improvements including reducing texture
pop-in instances also featured our
changes to quest hey I improvement you I
optimizations and support for dynamic
1080p scaling for the xbox one version
you can check out the full list of patch
notes in our story on gamespot so which
are three unlocks right now so your best
quit wasting
a time with me and go get stuck into it
if you picked it up let me know what
genre you want to see more of and why
down in that comment section you can add
the game spot where we've got stories on
Casey husband moving from Microsoft and
Capcom but planning more remasters that
is everything I've got for you today
have fun playing The Witcher for those
of you whose got it and i'll catch you
again tomorrow